we are breaking news about heather
locklear the TV icon is back in
treatment again yeah and that is just
the beginning of our exclusive new
reporting here is everything happening
right now as Locklear battles to stay
sober
looking strong staying sober and taking
responsibility for her past et has
learned Heather checked into a
court-ordered treatment facility
yesterday on Friday the 57 year old TV
icon pled no contest to a misdemeanor
offenses of battery and resisting
officers the sentence stems from two
incidents last year the first occurred
February 25th when she was arrested on
charges of domestic violence and
misdemeanor battery on a police officer
this was Heather looking like the
picture of health earlier this summer in
LA one person who has seen Heather's
remarkable transformation firsthand TV
host and good friend of more than 20
years
jillian Barberie we spoke with her on
the phone today on Monday of course he
went to the facility after her she's
like checking into the fourth season or
the joke concerns a picture of like the
check-in facility whatever they call it
when I talked her about doing this piece
today she's like whatever she's just
very cool and unguarded the to talk
every day and Jillian says Heather has
been a huge pillar of strength for her
own grueling breast cancer back he just
helped me through some really dark times
cancer or addiction we all have demons
to face she doesn't feel sorry for
herself at all she knows that she's got
to do and she's doing it she's healthy
and happy sober and is just in a really
good place I'm so proud of her
[Music]